c'est en direct avec nous pour en parler
pierre guérin est professeur émérite de
civilisation américaine ap à l'anis et
spécialiste des états unis bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors que retenez vous
de ces quelques jours de discussions
entre les deux puissances mondiales
alors je la première chose qui est
intéressant c'est que blinken a décidé
de laisser les caméras des médias lors
des déclarations qu'il a faites devant
les délégués chinois
c'est tout à fait inhabituel
habituellement les médias sur le début
et puis pour les discussions c'est en
secret il s'agissait donc d'abord d'un
message adressé à la base électorale des
démocrates aux états unis ça c'est le
premier point
évidemment ensuite ce qui est important
c'est qu'on est dans une lutte
géopolitiques entre les deux premières
puissances mondiales et selon un certain
nombre d'indicateurs la chine pourrait
dépasser les états-unis en 2050
donc il ya une tension très vive qui
fait monter l'animosité et de côté alors
comment décririez-vous ans pour
l'instant la ligne politique joe biden
adoptent face à la chaîne alors bye 2
dont on ne sait pas quel est l'état
mental quand même il faut dire ça et son
entourage ont été accusées dans la
campagne patronne des pro chinois dont
ils vont faire tout pour montrer qu'ils
ne sont pas pro chinois et ils ont un
scénario de critiques de la chine qui
passe par les droits la violation des
droits humains les ouigours ou bien hong
kong
autrefois il y avait le tibet alors il
ya certainement des problèmes très
graves de droits humains en chine
c'est indéniable maintenant que je ne
sais pas si c'est vraiment génocide des
ouigours parce que la personne qui met
ça en avance et adrian ce qui est peu
fiable
mais les états unis ne sont pas très
crédible lorsqu'on parle de droits
humains
ils soutiennent l'arabie saoudite qui
est
dans tout le monde c'est un des pays qui
violent les droits humains notamment des
femmes de ta son empire au monde
donc la rhétorique sur les droits et mas
est une façon de faire de la propagande
mais de la propagande qui vise surtout à
solidifier un quant aux états unis
d'autre part la chine avait que ces
techniques et économiques la route de la
soie la nouvelle route de l'espace
intérieur investi et intervient dans un
grand nombre de pays et donc elle a une
approche qui est beaucoup plus qui est
beaucoup moins militariste que les états
jeudi mais qui passe par l'économie les
investissements et les accords des
développements dans presque tous les
pays de la planète
donc la lutte se situe là se situe au
niveau de la prédominance économique
sur quel sujet les deux puissances
ont-elles enterrait à s'entendre alors
le premier sujet c'est évidemment la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
parce que les états unis et la chine
sont en les deux plus gros pollueurs du
monde
donc ces deux pays non seulement pollue
plus que les autres mais s'ils
s'entendaient ça pourrait faire une
grosse différence sur le réchauffement
climatique
et là on peut espérer puisque les deux
pays où donner des signaux positifs sur
ce plan que eelv ya quelque chose qui
est possible à un accord tout le monde a
intérêt à ce que chine et états unis
réduisent leurs émissions et voilà un
domaine où la coopération est possible
sur l'iran effectivement la chine ainsi
que d'autres pays la russie la france
l'allemagne la grande-bretagne était
partisan de la porte était signée en
2015 dans bailon avait dit qu'il le
rejoindrai mais depuis qu'il est au
pouvoir c'est à dire deux mois donne des
signaux un peu contradictoire mais là il
ya un domaine où effectivement si on
peut penser à une diplomatie rationnelle
de la part de tous les acteurs laisserai
nationale
revenir à cet accord pour apaiser un
petit peu le moyen-orient il est
possible sur ce plan là un accord sont
encore possibles alors on connaît les
relations sino-américaines dressé par
donald trump quel état des lieux en fait
nous en fait
en politique étrangère il ya une très
grande continuité entre trump hebeisen
de même qu'ils avaient grande continuité
entre bush et obama obama est un
contrairement aux déclarations
enflammées réthoré quelquefois un peu
folle de tonnes
ce regard par exemple sur le venezuela
sur israël sur la chine
il n'ya pas une différence énorme c'est
à dire hostilité et affirment et parce
que le fondamentalement les réseaux
position géopolitique soit
indépendamment de la personne qui est au
pouvoir
elia par ailleurs un complexe militaro
industriel qui est derrière chacun des
présidents et qui pousse dans une
direction aux états unis en chine
évidemment c'est le parti communiste
donc les lignes de force sont
déterminées par des invités des groupes
qui ne sont pas que le président donc la
continuité entre départ d administration
américaine n'est pas étonnante puisque
toutes les forces qui détermine la
politique étrangère restent les mêmes
donc peu peu de grands changements sauf
gbagbo ne va pas insulter ses alliés
mais il assume ses ennemis mais il va
pas insulter c'est gagné donc au niveau
de la forme il ya des différences et sur
le climat on peut penser que la
différence fondamentale l'autrement
énormément de continuité pierre guerlain
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct sur rt front se rappelle que vous
êtes un professeur aimé de civilisation
américaine a pas renier ces spécialistes
des a's états unis merci